that's not the plan
okay we got I'm always trying to figure
out the Dynamics of your love life blue
because it is very yeah from week to
week
I don't know what they're saying I saw
you just where you just performed at the
uh the fight that that was a wild damn
it I mean the whole night that was a
wild night but but but again like you
perform with Chris uh obviously you're
you're with your your girl right here
all right are you guys in a relationship
are you guys what's happening here like
what's the status of blue like what are
you doing we are depending on what week
it is yeah I think so
business it's like I'd rather get money
with somebody
then get money by myself not to play at
the point that I'm at and then some
people they want to get money by
themselves for me so it's like okay me
and Rock who's getting money together
and then
you know I guess she felt the type of
way I mean I'm more in the music side
and I feel like she's more on the TV
side like she's more into this well you
guys have a team I mean you guys ever
showed you crazy yeah no no but I'm
saying I only indulged in these ideas to
benefit the music for her you know I
didn't do it thinking like yeah that's
that's pretty Superstar reality TV yeah
you know I do music so it's like okay
I'm as these opportunities come in I'm
like okay yeah we should do it it's
gonna better your music better your
music more promotion more promotion but
she kind of felt more in love with that
right so she kind of like made
relationships in that field in that lane
and you know like that's not my Lane so
right I'm not gonna try to jump into
that lane to like so yeah so I just had
to like take a step back and let her
pursue that but Jaden she's doing we
doing just music like you know we're
gonna take a different route and it's
gonna be a different Lane it's gonna be
a different kind of a whole different
how many songs do you have today just
the one just the one yeah it's only been
like two days I'm gonna say it's been
quick because like if you just decide
you want to rap a month ago oh yeah yeah
no we just put it out like two days ago
or so like Friday I mean I mean how many
songs do you have that are just that
you've recorded or is this just that
that was my first time ever in the
studio
[Music]
if you guys go on a double date she's
got to be like I'm Little Mermaid what
am I doing at this bowling alley with
blueface and his roster I mean I don't
know roster I don't know
you know from
what are the lessons you've learned from
just a lot of the because you've been
through a lot blue uh we've seen a lot
of [__] pop off whether it's
uh by the way shout out to you uh for
going to my club she was puking in the
parking lot went viral
are there any less
learned in terms of just trying to
maneuver this entertainment industry
while also being very forthcoming with
your personal life
man even from
from like everything I learned a lesson
from even to rock and the ddg and how
they [__] even from I just learned that
you know certain people
shouldn't meet you know and it'll
prevent everything type thing so
I learned from every everything that you
got in mind about how how is this going
to work out how is this going to work
out I've learned from all of those
things and it's gonna work out because
I'm not even gonna entertain those those
Avenues right we're gonna focus on the
music I'm gonna help music
music videos out let's go to Runway
let's go to let's go to like right
if we're not making no music we ain't
doing it